at 62 my dick is like buddy holly's
playing like it's like
[ __ ]
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
support for the oh my god hi podcast is
brought to you in part by our friends at
manscaped gentlemen father's day is just
around the corner and our friends at
manscaped are here to ensure that all
the father figures out there are looking
daddy material this june manscape's
performance package 4.0 which includes
their signature lawnmower 4.0 is the
perfect bundle to tackle any and all old
man hair from head to toe this right
here is no dad joke so get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code omg hi at
manscape.com trust me his dad bod will
thank you
big thanks to our new sponsor medterra
in mediterra they crafted trusted
effective and accessible cbd products
that support deeper sleep relaxation and
relief so go to m-e-d-t-e-r-r-a-dot-com
o-m-g-h-i and enter code o-m-g-h-i at
checkout for 30 off plus free shipping
on your first order
so i told my wife i said hey i'm going
to mom's birthday but you're not invited
i said i ain't taking it because i know
i
and she said no i don't want to go why
would she put that she won't let you
have fun no
the guy you know it's like being around
guys guys will talk
you know what then
she doesn't need to hear that [ __ ]
no no how about that guys will talk she
doesn't need to hear that [ __ ] no no
she's sister mary clarence
you know she's all right let's get to it
man finally talking about molly shannon
why don't we have something finally we
have some talent i know you don't drink
because asian people are usually is this
alcohol yeah yeah oh my god i mean i do
drink i just look crazy
that's what i want to say man why is it
that that uh
that that culture gets really red when
and you know i was with this girl and
we're at my house party and she goes i
said have a drink she goes no i don't
drink it i get really red and then she
had a margarita in her hand i said i
thought you didn't go [ __ ] she was like
she looked like a strawberry [ __ ]
inflamed yeah my my grandmother
dragged you [ __ ] drank that much my
grandson his dad
is dutch indonesian
and so my grandson has his blood and he
just has a couple and he turns beet red
his dad and he's like turning a red
light on i mean it's incredible when
when van halen like his dutch indonesian
one betty van halen i went uh to the
desert it was really hot and then i
looked over at him and he was pink like
really pink i go hey man you know you're
the color that i like my salmon
[Laughter]
you're the perfect color of a beautiful
salmon nice medium like just that like
pink
yeah that pink glow and it happened fast
with driving i look at how far away
[Laughter]
it is
it thinks the genealogy on
i think there's an enzyme that it's
missing oh the enzymes i don't know that
sounds real no i i just look like i
heard it somewhere
is there yeah it's an enzyme deficiency
uh the enzyme is called aldehyde
dehydrogenase yeah that's what i told my
grandson
whatever grant you said that we would
not have that one yeah we have
we have yours we have we have one that
we're not supposed to have we took all
the ones from the asian culture latinos
have two that we can drink and never get
and we try even not to live you know our
whole [ __ ] lives were ruled by women
who are like are you high ah are you
drunk
are you
our women will never ask that because
it's obvious you're drunk
and have you ever met a korean that's
drunk
a drunk korean
you know i have man it gets scary
it gets really scary
where did you where were you born i was
born in flushing queens
you know just south of korea
yeah flushing yeah where the mets are
from yeah exactly and the nanny
that's right and the nanny
and and uh my reference
and when did you
how did you start doing comedy
um how did i start doing comedy who did
you did you watch
i mean uh did i watch growing up
well when i was 16 i was deeply closeted
and i all my friends all my korean
friends
they were
you know going clubbing and stuff and i
clearly didn't want to go clubbing so i
would you know get a um
buy two drinks at the comedy cellar and
sit in the back oh wow and just watch
comedians david tell was my favorite
like the fact the way dave attel talked
for me a closeted gay
um you know uh evangelical christian boy
like that was freedom he almost you know
it's not there but it sounds
long long time forever yeah and he
hasn't really had i don't think specials
that have had the opportunity for a lot
of people to see him but the people who
who are in comedy are in the know love
david tell me i just love hearing him on
the radio yeah he's on the radio oh yeah
all i listen most of the time is
comedy radio oh oh really yeah oh wow i
can't okay so you're sitting back there
you're sitting back there and you're
watching these guys and then you figure
do you think i i want to do this hell no
i was like this can't this is not for me
like this they were magicians you know
for me it was like watching moses coming
down you know like it was like god like
almost it's not the easy when a guy when
a guy is doing well yeah
they can make it look easy but if
somebody can't do it it looks like the
hardest [ __ ] thing to do is the
hardest thing for you first of all you
have to get the plane in the air first
if you're an airplane
you're getting on the runway like hey
how's everybody doing you know
uh and then you gotta hit right away you
don't hit the first and you don't hit
the second third one now you're running
out of the place where people are gonna
start to say [ __ ] this guy's kind of
yeah you have no runway left
you gotta you gotta hit them and let
them know that yeah that they're about
to see something yeah
so i i didn't see i mean the only person
i saw doing it was bobby lee
and um margaret cho who my mom was like
you can't watch her she's gay
as if by me watching again
the funniest game yeah
um i have a funny story with margaret
cho she doesn't know me from anyone you
know but early in my comedy career i saw
her like at some av club thing and
afterwards i was like uh i don't want to
beat that guy but i love you and can i
give you a hug and she was like
yeah
and like she gave me like she was like
this and i gave her a hug i was like it
was as if i was hugging my family and
she was just like
okay
but she is very special matt margaret
margaret is very i i i've known margaret
for over 30 years and she's very special
i love her work she's oh yeah funny but
she found that i mean tv wasn't the
thing for her i mean clearly it's not
for everybody but the fact that she
found herself and then is able to just
be so smart and yeah open to
a lot of things that were almost taboo i
mean you know as an asian almost in any
culture that if someone is homosexual
that that
that is considered
i'm not
against everyone it's like it's not
against everyone people that don't agree
with it especially in latino community
and other cultures man yeah you know and
it's a very difficult thing to
because if you are you are
and
you know it causes a rift in the family
and the fathers and moms and the
brothers and the sisters and that just
doesn't make it easier on somebody that
you love
and now all of a sudden you know if they
come out
yeah they lose they they're they're hurt
now they're hurting they're trying to be
themselves but then they're hurting
because they've come out and everybody
that is supposed to love them is is
looking at them like you know
what did we do wrong he didn't do
anything wrong did you talk to my dad
you guys speaking oh i thought you were
dead
but you know what because i you know
and comedy's the perfect place for it
you know and even even actors you know
in movies in the 50s that were a little
bit they called it like faye or lil faye
yeah we're getting the biggest laps and
then if they found out that they were
what do you say
i mean what are they gay that that that
there was a guy that
forget the actor he was he was walking
across the street in new york casting
director saw him and said i love your
face and then the guy said oh i'm
breaking it in for a friend
and
the dude started laughing he's like wait
i gotta get your number he came down
here
got work as an actor but clearly was not
straight and they said to him
they brought him into the studio head
and they said
you can work forever
but just we you can't be seen with a man
you have to we have to set you up with a
woman
i wish someone said that to me i would
have taken the deal i'm just like no
one's over there
literally no one's offering something
when you come to town i'm like hello
i'm ready to sell my boyfriend up seven
years out like you could be the cleaning
boy
you know and he would have been able to
continue but he said no and he became an
interior designer and the interior
designers are the stars and he worked
forever oh good billy sheehan i think it
might be his name billy shearer billy
sheehan but
you know
this
i think the world view of it
did your life become easier when you
came out way harder
it was way harder i you know it's
interesting because like internal
externally my life was way easier when i
was in the closet obviously because you
just paint by the numbers and you just
it's a lot of what i see now is how i
felt before i came out was just
so scared that i didn't want to disrupt
anything like just keep everything
make sure no one's questioning you know
like i would go out with my straight
friends and they'd all be like let's go
dance up on these girls and i would be
like dancing with these girls having a
great time because i love to dance right
but also i'm like you know like you're
better than him you know and i'm like
i'm [ __ ] walking and i'm like i'm sorry
guys like i'm i i love you and you're my
friends but these are women and i have
to protect them so like exactly it
didn't go well so like i finally had to
come out and my friends were like
that makes sense
this is why you can't come here when you
came out
i came out to my family at 30.
but i came out to my friends earlier
like 27.
earlier but i'm like man 27 years i was
evangelical like i was speaking in
tongues you know what i mean like yeah
and i now you know after i came out i
was doing different things with tongues
like it just
unholy stuff
and
when you're gay and you're in church
like all that stuff that they say
they're like you're going to go to hell
for it becomes almost fetishized you
know because you're like you can't do
this you can't do that you know like in
catholicism too like you know latinos
you you experience that as well it's all
this like shame and pressure around
something so like
what should just be natural becomes like
almost fetishize and demonize it like
ooh you know like i was with somebody
yesterday and they said you know i'm
after i leave here i'm going to have
lunch with my gay friend and i said
i said how about when chicano see each
other
they look at each other across the room
and they go like this
and if someone you have a friend that's
gay and he sees your when they go
we're over here
like
would you love to just have people happy
to see you they're screaming even if you
went to hell oh yeah
flames all around they're like oh we're
over here
all the gays are in hell too so you know
what i mean like you're all like yes
it's a party like everybody
you know
everybody's telling everybody how to
live but yet
they nobody wants someone get their own
[ __ ] lives yeah it really doesn't
matter i'm not like everybody else
i've got a 44 year old son he came out
probably when he was a
early 20s i guess
and
i just told the wife does it really
surprise you and if that's the worst
thing did you know did you know or not
no i felt it i i felt it he was always
just a little soft
and like
when he saw him in the morning he was
moisturizing
his elbows good morning
i remember asking why do you have to
talk like that you know i i do remember
questioning what was he talking like
like a gay guy yeah yeah like a feminist
yeah yeah and i said
just talk right son it's all right
and i didn't you know i just
i'd hear that yeah but then i remember
coming back i'd been in panama for two
weeks uh teaching i come back the wife
met me at the airport the kids were
there were in separate cars and
i started the car my wife was just the
wife and i in the car said stop i got to
get it out of my chest and she started
crying and the first thing in my mind
was all [ __ ] what did i do now yeah and
she said i said what is it she says your
son came out of the closet
and i just told her i said
and
and is
is that it
i said is it what i wanted for my son
absolutely not because it'll make life
more difficult for him in the future but
i love my son he's not in the dope he's
not being arrested he's not a criminal
that's my son and i support anything he
wants to do yeah and then she told you
he was a bottom
i take back everybody
all right
my son is gay what department is he in
yeah
brush himself he's a bottom no
and the bottom is explain
explain the bottom to people who would
hear i'm a top is it all right is it
this is my camera
is it almost like i remember it used to
be pitcher or catcher yeah that's what
it's the same thing picture and catcher
okay should we just demonstrate it
bottom is the person that is
um receiving
the catcher yeah the catching the d or
receiving or
hosting the d okay you know and and
they're not the other they don't go like
you know sometimes in little league if a
guy didn't have the glove you'd leave it
out there and then he'd pick it up and
use it and then you'd leave it out there
again
do you can you can you rotate top and
bottom or the bottom of that we aren't
your first attack we had those in the
jail
when i was working the jails the sheriff
yeah well not with the sheriff the
inmates
you know they had the gay cells you know
well yeah
and i think that's where i would want to
be in the gate because in every cell
cell what are we talking about the
potential what can we do to this room
we had them segregated
the studs
the studs yes
those were those are the pictures yeah
those are the pictures
and the rest of them were the catchers
yeah but they were they had to be
separated otherwise like the whorehouse
you know everybody's having a good time
yeah can i ask you was it
were they separated by like
hair color height
what they said oh how they claimed yeah
okay so it didn't no there was no like
kind of definitive no matter
obviously some of them were obvious
want to know how to tell what a top
looks like
very obvious
like peanut size well no no
even in jail they would get uh red uh
not not cram markers red markers yeah
and they they'd get a hold of them and
put makeup on themselves
they'd get
tank tops you know and then they got
like eaters wife beaters they'd get them
and they'd cut them and they tie them up
here to make them look like feminine uh
crop tops yeah crop tops you know what i
heard that's so creative
i just got a text that the la shares
department at the county jail has just
opened up a sephora
[Laughter]
this is why you don't defund the police
yeah but but
as as as as
i hate to say racism is too easy a term
as people have bias towards each other
uh-huh
why why i mean i saw something that you
were at second city
my daughter got into second city
it's wonderful um
did someone yell something out about
mexicans in second city to you oh my god
yes it was it was crazy i mean they
people are yelling all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] but it's an improv thing right so
it's not a it's not necessarily you
would it would be a racist environment
second city is the oldest comedy troupe
maybe the oldest comic troupe in chicago
it's where uh john belushi and bill
murray and and all of the great snl like
a pipeline sure from second city uh go
to saturday night live and it's the most
prestigious i think you could get into
and be a performer
in comedy the first time i heard it but
no i'm just kidding uh no but you know
that yeah yeah it's like getting into
harvard if harvard had a department of
comedy yeah getting into second seed
because not easy and you audition and
you have the edition again and you have
to get in if you get in yeah it's very
prestigious
it was uh it was it was a really big
show in chicago and it was a time right
when um the end of like election stuff
was happening right it was like we
opened in april and the election was in
november and it was we can tell from and
it you know
at that time the theater
um you know it's summertime there's a
lot of
um
people visiting so it's not you know
it was a theater that it was open to a
lot of tourists you know not per se
chicagoans right but anyway you get like
a litmus test when you do like a big
theater like you have a litmus test of
like who's visiting chicago and what
america feels like at that point and
there was a lot of stuff happening and
that particular night
um
we do this improv piece where we like
ask for a suggestion of something that
annoys you and then we do like a big
like whatever and um
i was the person who went out and was
like sir
you know what something small that
annoys you and it was a white guy and
his wife and a mexican couple next to
them and they were like they just he
just looked at him and he was like
sitting next to a mexican holy [ __ ] and
i was like
are you [ __ ] kidding me and i like
screamed at him
and told our um and i looked at our uh
stage manager our house manager i was
like
what the [ __ ] and we had talked about
these racist comments happening before
and we had had multiple meetings about
like
what are we gonna do how are we gonna
like make sure we feel safe and the
audience feels safe and blah blah and it
it's such it's just like an ugly thing
that we don't necessarily we don't have
to deal with like you know and
um anyway so that was like my straw when
i was like
i don't want to keep doing stuff like
this where
um when i could just have to stand up
and be up there alone with the
microphone right
that's way more fun for me and that's
when like i turned from
like doing sketch comedy and improv too
just like full time yeah doing
things on my own and i i never have to
like open myself up to like what do you
think audience member like that's like
the worst thing a comic could do is like
offer
ask a question
but also it tells you about somebody who
is running for an office who has made it
okay for you to call other people out
yeah and be like flippantly joking about
something that is a real problem and you
know and it's
it just felt ugly and it was time to go
yeah yeah
in in uh
in the
election of of that
i was at uh foxwoods in connecticut and
i had mine with me like flown out there
my daughter who was at second city and
some dude yells out to me go back to
mexico
no in the toward the end of the
[ __ ] thing and i said who said that
and there was some guy in the aisle
and uh you know you don't want to blow
up the whole show and you just like
you know whatever i said uh and it's
just you know at a time when you had
been doing it for so long like i'm
saying you know as i look back
and
you know i'm not i love stand-up i
always have but i i don't want to leave
at a time when
it's a bad time yeah you know if you
leave in a down market you don't want to
leave when when it's um when it's on an
up sure yeah yeah and you know i'm not
sure that
um
guys who
i wouldn't say followed in my footsteps
but are of the same particular color
have taken up
for the people the way that they
not that they're responsible to
but i think that we have a
an array of different comedians who are
of color who that doesn't mean anything
to them and it means it meant everything
to me
that that i spoke up for people who
couldn't speak up for themselves instead
you have you know
guys who
never want to you know i think the
election you saw it where guys
would back off against issues and not
say anything in their act about anything
yeah and just try to be liked even on
instagram there's a lot of huge
tremendous amount of latino entertainers
who went silent during all of all of
that time and still and still are
because they didn't want to lose gay
they didn't want to lose their gigs they
didn't want to lose
potential followers but you know what do
you leave i mean
when i when i picked aside and was
anti-right
um
is when i started to receive death
threats not that it frightens me it's
like i don't even [ __ ] about death
they're all [ __ ] anyways okay i'll
tell you the i've i know i'm sure you've
received way more than me
um just because you're more famous
um but um i did receive one recently
that was so funny
it was after someone watched some dumb
video i did for pbs
um and they said wait a minute pbs
doesn't do dumb videos what was it it
was it was like
okay it i'll i'll just share it later it
was like the thing about like how it was
this was literally in 2016 i said it was
about how white supremacy is not
what we all think it is it's like kkk
and blah blah it's very like small micro
stuff
like when you ask um when people ask me
where are you from
and instead you would never ask a white
person where are you from you know
because you just think they deserve to
be here whereas you're always
kind of encroaching you're like can i be
at the party you know like you're always
like looking in like can i be here
um anyway i did it way funnier than that
anyway so um
uh judy woodruff laughed and that was my
career
and uh
yeah
um but anyway because of that video i
get a lot of these death threats and one
one of them was
um
you can i say [ __ ] yeah you [ __ ] i'm
going to take my broomstick and shove it
up your
ass um
which i thought was
the gayest thing to say
just lube it up first yeah i mean sure
it's a little thin for my taste
[Laughter]
but you know we'll start something about
the girl
i'm five inches but some guys like it
that yeah
hey i've always said i'm hung like a
tuna can
it's like a bathtub plug
yeah those things is this really going
out on
here this is this live i think we just
got this oh my god but but
is was that on instagram or mailed to
you um it was on my website i finally
like
closed down my like contact me because
i'm like why are you contacting me right
i just did it because i saw other
websites have a contact me but like sure
anyway so people started emailing me
crazy [ __ ] and i i shut that down and
then people like reach out to me on
instagram and say but also but also
if you are concerned with what people
think of you you will never have a
career you will never be identified you
will never be at peace no you know i've
said things that
have have warranted a visit from the
secret service oh
and
nothing
would make me
silence unless they came back and
literally took me away in cuffs because
i kept doing it you know
i've decided that
they're good the people that aren't
gonna like you are gonna like you
anyways and and trying to trying to make
everybody you know somebody said i mean
the guy was a rapist but somebody said
i can't tell you what the secret to
success is but the secret to failure is
trying to make everyone happy
donald trump said that yeah
it was more wait a minute i think but
george i don't realize i'm an informant
for the secret service
that's the only reason you're getting a
call hang on a
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know there is no one [ __ ] way to
make it the only way to make it is to be
you and part of being you is all of
those things as a police officer i
remember a friend of mine was a highway
patrolman and he pulled over somebody
right there off the of the 101 and the
guy that liked beef sticks
no that was that was over in santa
clarita you know that was the weapo
yeah
but this guy this guy went up behind the
car and as he walked up behind the car
the guy was turned this way so early
that he looked at him he said i'm gonna
go around to the right side of the car
and the dude had a he had a he had a gun
sure like this but i said what made you
do that he goes i had an instinct but
also the dude was turned this way too
too early and i thought well that's not
a good thing and then he he couldn't see
me because of the blind spot in the
thing
and i went around this side and he he
was like this like he [ __ ] shot him
whoa
if you look at a lot a lot of that's
good that one one-man cars do that often
put that light man in the mirror they're
their rumor so they can't see
and then come around the right side
right and that's it you see that but
that's right in the mirror yeah and i
can't see in the mirror
that's a good sign but instincts are are
a proper thing to to follow
ladies and gentlemen father's day is
just around the corner i don't know
about you i come from a pretty sort of
hairy lineage myself which is why we're
excited to talk to you again about our
friends at manscaped so manscape is
designed with fathers in mind not just
this time of year but all year round and
the performance package 4.0 is here just
in time for that special day father's
day i'll tell you what's in the package
first they have their lawnmower 4.0
trimmer
which is a weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer a crop preserver ball
deodorant crop reviver toner performance
boxer briefs and a travel bag to hold
all those goodies in
first off let me start by saying the
lawnmower 4.0 will be the official mvp
of father's day so fourth generation
trimming technology that they're working
with now it's got a cutting edge ceramic
blade to reduce grooming accidents it's
got advanced skin safe technology it's
waterproof it even has a 400k led
spotlight for a very very precise
beautiful perfect shave we all know dads
love their comfort it's the summer it's
hot
the boxers 2.0 which this also comes
with are here to save every father from
that uncomfortable heat dads buy this
for yourself sons buy this for your dad
ladies buy this for your man and dog
daddies you guys deserve a treat too
okay so get 20 off plus free shipping
with the code omghi
at manscaped.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
omghi
shake what your mama gave you no shake
what your daddy gave you
support for the oh my god high podcast
is brought to you in part by medterra
medterra was a group founded by friends
passionate about bringing cbd to those
who love it most if you haven't heard of
cbd and where have you been frankly it
can promote relaxation sleep and a slew
of other benefits
topicals like the hemp infused manuka
cream and on the go pain relief roll
help you balance your skin and body and
mind they also have tasty sweets like
the full spectrum deep sleep gummies to
support your journey in finding deep
restorative sleep that helps you lead to
a rejuvenated day sleep is very
important people
you know modern life is so busy that we
often put our recovery and things like
rest sort of at the back of the line
even though these things should be our
first priority health is wealth you know
what i'm saying
medterra has designed high quality
accessible and easy to incorporate
wellness solutions like their manuka
cream and pain relief roll on to support
that sort of daily wellness
so i'm a cbd fan myself i think this
stuff is super effective super powerful
um
i love this brand they've been working
with them for a little bit and it's easy
to use it's low cost it's high quality
and it's just sort of everything you
want out of a product like this
it has industrial hemp grown in america
and is u.s hemp authority certified
that's right they've got the
certification and all the products are
third party tested non-gmo and contain
organic ingredients and are even grain
free
so omg high listeners get 30 off and
free shipping on their order with
medterra go to medterra.com
omghi and enter code omghi at checkout
that's medterra.com
omghi and enter code omghi at checkout
for 30 off and free shipping
now what what um when did you decide to
move from from
from the east coast to los angeles
uh it took a little that's a big that's
a big deal because you have to you have
to say like okay i think i'm good enough
to be able to go to la and start working
but when you get here
you realize as a comedian how [ __ ]
big the city is and then of course
you're gonna go to the lab factory and
you're going to pass by the comedy store
and they're going to look
[ __ ] huge you're going to be oh my
god it's a comedy story that's this the
improv and they're going to look like
places that you could never get into
yeah and a bit it's you it's you're
almost like your eyes are too big for
your stomach
you're like how am i
as a comedian
going to try to make
a career out of places where at the
comedy store everybody's names who's
ever worked there the biggest names in
comedy have been they're like how do how
am i going to make
an impression in this town but to move
here is i think it's overwhelming for a
comedian absolutely it was i regretted
it immediately but i um
i i grew up in new york and i started
comedy and sf actually i was work i
spent seven years it was hacked that was
a good move what is sf
san francisco and i was um
i didn't go into comedy at first i
finished college and i became a
data scientist for yahoo
so i was doing that for seven years
making like a great living you know
nouveau ridge just like [ __ ] up san
francisco and like kicking out poor
people you know like being the douchebag
and
i was like i hate my life i was still in
the closet so when i came i came out
actually
at a open mic
because i it was my second open mic and
i
i remember thinking like oh that's big
man that's that's huge man i don't know
i mean has anybody ever come out on
stage
carmichael just did in a special oh yeah
and he had never done it before until
the special i believe so yeah it was
like a huge deal yeah um so you know he
stole from me
but i
no i'm kidding i i i
i but you have to say that here we go
you have to you have to say to yourself
here we go this is going to change
everything
you know and i and i knew that
the anonymity
that um
and the protection of a
shitty bar in san francisco in the
richmond district
where and it stunk it was a dive bar and
it was me up there with six other
comedians in the crowd just looking at
their own notebooks or their phone you
know it was just so
i knew that was the place i had to do it
because
i knew that
it would be the safest i didn't know
anyone there so anonymity felt safe in
that way so i came out i said
well i'm peter and i'm gay and
people just looked at me like
okay you're asian
and you're gay in san francisco
so do you have a joke you know
yeah where's the punchline yeah yeah
like that's your setup and that's i felt
so liberated at that moment where i was
like
oh i'm holding on to this
like this is me and i would
i had all these ideas of like if if only
my family if only this if only that but
i'm the one holding on to this thing so
i have to be the one to let it down and
that's when everything changed and i
started doing comedy and
um i quit my job and moved out to
chicago to do second city and
um i moved out here in the fall of 2017.
and uh that's when everything was done
with second city and i was like you know
it's time to go to l.a wow
and um
yeah and now i'm here it changed
everything didn't it it really did once
once you were able to do that
you were free right you felt you had to
feel like you were
like i don't know i don't know what it's
like to have to feel like a weight's
been lifted off of you
but you had to feel like you're not
going back to a place where you're
saying you're where you're gonna go on
stage and say you're not gay yeah from
now from going forward you would have to
be honest approach it as you would be
yourself now exactly
and i i think i don't think i would have
gone i would have gotten there
eventually but i don't think i would
have gone there as quickly
if not for comedy because
comedy i think
what it did for me and everyone else who
does it is it forces you to be
yourself your voice and
and and claim your voice
and before i came out i was pretending
to be someone and everybody knew like
the whole audience they're like sharks
you know like they know immediately that
you're bullshitting like if you ever see
like a comic try to do like some premise
that he like saw someone else doing and
wants it's so obvious that that's not
coming from you
and that's what made me
come out because
i wanted to be better at comedy right
and that meant and just being a better
artist in general just means
be more yourself
right and be more confident with
yourself and who you are and
so yeah comedy
saved my life i mean
there you go i have fun with it i really
do and i know george heard the story my
son
i was doing some ring announcing at
boxing matches one day and he comes up
to me and one of my daughter's friends
had just had breast augmentation
nice
[Laughter]
so my son comes up to me and he says hey
dad
she showed me her hooters and she was
showing them to the girls and she said
well i can show them to you because
you're gay i said son go back and tell
her your dad's gay too
i want to take a look at him
also
it didn't make a difference my son i
love you and he's good but you know i'm
lesbian right yeah
do they do is there is there a way to
uh enhance your penis didn't they have a
pump that would make blood come out it's
almost like it doesn't work i tried it
but you're trying to get the most amount
of blood to the tip right yeah it's
almost like at uh carnival when you have
the that the mallet and you're trying to
hit it to ring the bell you're trying to
get the blood to rush to the tip
wait a minute hang on a second i've
tried them all
at 62 my dick is like buddy holly's
playing like it's like
[ __ ]
[ __ ] wings like this
like that running out of the runway
you're trying to [ __ ] get it just
level hey and it just [ __ ] crashes
there
you can't lead a horse to water you
can't force a dick into a hole
wait a minute
you can't lead a horse to water and you
can't put
a dick into a hole a tepid dick into a
hole oh yes attempted it's like trying
to
what they say was like trying to play
pool with it with a noodle
[Laughter]
but i mean the mind the mind is uh my
mind is fresh you know what a guy told
me years ago he was in he was in a band
and i just got married and he said i
want to give you some advice you just
got married he goes make sure your dick
gets as hard for home games as it does
for away games because when you're on
the road
everything's new to you and everything's
fresh and new and then you get home and
now you're almost like on appointment
and sometimes you can't perform at home
because the excitement of being out
is is is more
the the allure of it is better than you
know being in a bed and like
okay we're going to do it in this thing
uh i you know for a second i thought you
were talking about comedy but it works
both ways i think i i think it might be
yeah
is it because they say
like is thomady would comedy be the top
or the bottom
comedy is always the toughest
uh pretending to be honest yeah yeah
yeah but but but however you know
there's
you know when you're on the road or
you're doing whatever
there's more time there's way too much
time that's vacant than there's a time
on the stage and there has to be
somebody you have to you have to stay
connected to what you love or else you
you know you go rogue man are you still
on the road do you do the road yeah i do
i i'm still doing some stuff yeah do you
still enjoy it i do yeah i just went
back east to uh um uh
white plains or west chester montclair
and then westbury which i love westbury
it's in the round and all that stuff but
yeah it's very good and i'm not kissing
his ass but he's still great oh i i i'm
not here but i mean i've gone to see him
he's not right here
but he's still learning here but i know
but you know i know i've been around so
i know what i'm talking about and i've
seen i've seen i've seen great people
not achieve
success i've seen people who aren't that
good become successful but
not respected and whatever whatever you
do in comedy the best thing to do is to
be true to yourself yeah in whatever
that is and whatever your truth is
um
it
whatever the universe does it rewards
somebody who's being honest so imagine
being
one of a million lights
and then one light turns red that's you
and the red light makes it and the white
lights just become other white lights
wow wow and the only way that you can
become a red light is to [ __ ] give a
[ __ ] about where you are and who you are
and what you do and who you're doing it
to
i think do i have a shot
yeah [ __ ] yeah you get four more
[Applause]
but you know what i'm saying i mean you
have to like and you know that you're
going to get better and that you and
that you get better you you
the voiceovers do you like the animation
you like
i love it yeah i love i love the
animation jobs it's i write for one how
did you get your first animation job
my first one was fairfax the um amazon
show and just
yeah i think a more famous person
dropped out or something because i i you
know i'm a nobody you know i came here
and i did
ncis there's the thing that every actor
has to get under your belt and get like
you know and then i did a um
oh my my comedy dream was to do kirby
enthusiasm and of course i get it and i
improvised with larry and
um john hamm in this wonderful scene and
then i'm telling everyone yes i did it i
reached my comedy dream and i'm like
yeah let's watch it and i'm completely
cut out of it
the whole scene the whole yeah the whole
like tag of the scene was cut out and i
was like oh my god it was mortifying but
it was one of those like it happens to
everyone there's still do you still
count as doing i think you yeah you'd
still get paid and so you know i was on
the curb enthusiasm and i was on one of
what is considered maybe one of the best
episodes
the episode where they revealed that
that richard lewis needed needed a
kidney and they go to the doctor
and that there's the the doctor's
daughter and it's i don't i don't know
what it's called but it's considered one
of the best
heinemann the dr heinemann
the one of the best episodes of curb
and uh
uh stephen
kojo the guy from et fell out and i just
had my transplant in 2005 and i had just
played golf with larry like the week
before and just like in curb larry calls
me and i go hello he goes what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i just saw you last week
what the [ __ ]
you didn't say anything i said well i
didn't want anybody to know but it's a
kidney what the [ __ ]
and then he said kojo fell out would you
consider you know filling back in for
him and what was it called uh the
episode is called the ski lift the ski
lift oh yeah yeah cool
and they ran into me in the hallway and
they said you had a transplant didn't
you i said yeah because richard lewis
needs a transplant i was like oh man
that's that's
that's pretty bad and then larry goes
isn't he gonna go on the bottom of the
list i said yeah he's [ __ ] i said if
it was richard lewis from 20 years ago i
think he's on the top of the list but
richard lewis nowadays he's [ __ ]
nobody knows who he is and then they go
all right thanks jordan take it easy man
autograph but but i mean i mean larry
you know you see those guys yeah i mean
you know that
when you
envision growing up and you're looking
in your tv and you see people that you
truly admire if you ever get to see one
i would always say with your own eyes
it's one of the most [ __ ] incredible
things that could happen to anybody who
have you seen
that you said like oh my god i can't
believe it for sure yeah that was like
it for me i i don't i didn't really i
grew up on seinfeld you know thursday
nights nbc like that's i had i was a
lash kick kid you know like tv raised me
right so like i'm a huge fan of tv and
um
just to be able to do it i don't care
that i was cut out honestly like it was
a couple of jokes and it was funny but
like just the experience alone was but
the idea the idea of being raised by a
tv is which is what you did which is
what i did sure i'm not sure
it was a lot of tv but now you couldn't
get a kid to sit in front of a tv i
think and do what you what because
they're doing the games and they're in
the phone raised by ipads now
there's a program right now that we're
hooked on and we watch all the time in
the house
all right
i say yes
but it's a korean show oh yeah bought a
market you know the
kim's convenience yes oh okay yeah great
have you seen all seven episodes i've
seen more than that it's a great show i
love it it's still on yeah i think
everything's like five seasons i think
just putting it they ran for a while
yeah yeah
but i didn't even have something
funny
it's it's really good it's all all
korean korean marketing
yeah really good i think there's
actually two koreans on the show but you
know that's how it always is that
happened to margaret cho's show
you know like
yeah i'm determined to make the first
korean american family
just two
the mother the father the son and the
son is chinese oh okay because he's gone
on to bigger things okay yeah yeah and
yeah cousin is i think filipino or
southeast asia let's talk about this
let's talk about if you say you're a
latino and you have a mexican family and
then one of the persons is cuban one
person's honduran and one of the persons
come from colombia which is would be
like if
you know
you're korean and then you have a
filipino you have a cambodian guy and
they're not is it an issue you think
in the community
it's interesting i i think today there
are enough of us working where we can
cast it accurately i think 20 years ago
it was hard to cast all koreans or all
you know whatever like how many episodes
did they do uh 65 episodes five seasons
for convenience yeah yeah it was on cbs
wasn't it it was it was a canadian
canadian so cbc yeah yeah was on
canadian yeah yeah and then i think
that's like their biggest show
distributed what about fresh off the
boat was was uh a show that had some
momentum and you know
i didn't like well another child it was
a chinese family randall park korean guy
yeah the family you know what i mean
like yeah yeah
does it matter does it matter to you
it matters to me as the storyteller now
when you break it down as like a
business
we got to make business decisions i
understand that but i think
for me when i'm casting my korean family
show yeah they're gonna need to be
korean like we're gonna be able to we're
i want the joy of it being absolutely
like have that shorthand with each other
that culturally creates for better
comedy because there's better
specificity okay exactly what he said so
so on my first show
i'm mexican-american valente was from
texas mexican uh lewis is mexican from
chicago uh constance was playing cuban
playing my wife angie
mexican but okay and then her father
my father-in-law was cuban my mom was
you know mexican so when valente first
started to do that
like all the little slang things and
then i started to do the slang things it
gave
the body of the show
a life yeah that was different than
everything because i would go
all that stuff and they they it became
like it hooked people to say oh my god
that's what it's authentic
so yeah i i agree on that point that
that if you have um
an array of cultures into a thing that
was supposed to be specifically one one
family that you lose those things and
those things
were so important to my show 30 episode
from 30 to 120 that i'm not sure if i
was surrounded by people who weren't of
my necessarily ethnicity that the show
would have suffered so i agree with you
i i i agree with that now i i didn't
understand it when i was a kid
when you had all these old shows where
they had
people playing uh american indians that
were indians yeah they put makeup on
them
white people playing mexicans yeah you
know all this fake [ __ ] you know and i
didn't realize it when i was a kid
growing up um because that was just that
now did i look at it did you realize
that charlie chan or mickey rooney with
those glasses how insulting
as a fam as a family back then did you
did your family watch american tv and
see those things like the charlie chan
or
mickey rooney playing that or like first
i'm like first first-gen but you've seen
those things right i've seen them
literally i didn't know about charlie
chanto i went to college and took a
class like i grew up watching only
korean tv yeah i don't know how like
first gen mexico
oh wow so i was esl i i was born in new
york and i remember kssl yeah
no essl english second language yeah and
it was so weird to have to go to esl
classes when all these kids were from
korea and i was from the bronx
and i was like this kid can't even speak
english i don't know what the [ __ ]
going on right because no one in my
family
spoke english
everyone acted like we were still in
korea wow you know and it was and
because it was the first generation of
people to come over as a diaspora wow
you know
we haven't been here that long like 70s
maybe 60s 70s
help this mexican out what's a diaspora
diaspora is like the cocktail that you
get
they light on fire then you blow it out
yeah
diaspora is what i get when i eat bad
shellfish
[Laughter]
what does it mean what does that mean it
means a group of people that have come
over come out of a country so jewish
diaspora is spread all over america and
you have you ever heard the word
diaspora i know i i never have that
that's why you asked
i was beaten into knowing those words
fart where you had to go to the pharmacy
to get that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so so
that's right and they haven't been that
long from like the 70s and things like
that and what issues did your parents
have
only speaking korean in in the bronx
well you know
mostly it was us getting evicted
by people who were like you're late on
rent but that's the only time we ever
spoke to anyone who spoke english when
they went to the store and they saw what
they liked and they so there was no
there was like korean markets yeah okay
there were there was like an
infrastructure a lot of church koreans
yeah so people hung out at church
together and
that became your social circle and
um koreans have this thing called keton
which is like a for lack of a better
phrase it's like a black market economy
where like families get together and put
in like ten thousand dollars oh you know
what that is okay yeah yeah you guys
haven't seen that no uh we have where
you we put in ten thousand and the next
guy takes it next guy takes it yeah
[ __ ] runs off
he buys rooms for his car yeah so he
shows up the next month like what's that
goes up it goes down
but you know what that's a they help
each other yeah that's the thing that's
what we do that's what immigrants do is
like we create a
counterculture subculture of people and
it's honest right so that you put money
in there
and then you get the money and your
family benefits from it and then another
friend will get it yeah and it's a way
to do loans asian community where i live
that's what they do to buy all the
property that's what they do buy houses
out there yeah
that's exactly it
what are you saying that you probably
that's your area's turning chinito
what's your area
i'm not afraid i live on roland heights
i mean i have one american
uh market there
everything else is you mean it rolling
heist there's only one american market
yes yes everything else is you know even
mcdonald's has asian writing on the on
the side yeah under it's it's all asian
writing i'm not sure and i i don't know
one from each country
i read write i'm
fluent yeah
i read writing in spanish and mexican
but
i mean it's an all asian community out
there where i live yeah
and i can remember when it wasn't but
that's all it is if
i've experienced where i wanted to buy
another house over there yeah i couldn't
even get a return call here you call me
and i'll hook you up yeah
all this the realtors were all asian
yeah
speaking asian there you go and they did
not so they didn't care
but you know the racism before now it's
you know it's out in the open but racism
used to be
where maybe uh you and i went to go look
at a car
and then we'd go hey how you doing i saw
your ad in the paper the person would go
oh sorry man i just i just sold the car
yesterday but isn't that it right there
no that's another one and the racism was
covert yeah where they would say we're
here to look at the apartment and they
would say oh you know i rented that
apartment
and then now they would say i'm not
running that apartment to a [ __ ] wet
back
and then you'd be like
oh oh okay and then now you get right
now you're into it it's almost we went
backwards we went backwards yeah because
it used to be this like
stupid like go back to your country that
kind of stuff like i thought we elevated
the conversation of racism and we but
we've stripped our education system we
don't know how to like make make racism
poetic again we're still shooting people
because of the colors i mean we should
be so far beyond going into a market and
shooting [ __ ] people certainly
i know it's just that and and hate for
for hate
when the world is so open man and that
this [ __ ]
a kid that's 18 would throw his [ __ ]
life away over some [ __ ] that was
taught to him and that he didn't learn
himself nobody at 18 could learn to hate
that many people unless they're
influenced by [ __ ] that they find on the
internet or or whatever it's just
impossible because by the time you start
to realize who you are you're probably
seven that's 11 years to hate people
that much that you would write a hundred
and eighty page manifest i don't even if
i [ __ ] if i talk about [ __ ] i
couldn't write 180 pages
but it's sad man to think that that's
where we are man and that that you know
that those lives are all [ __ ] been
destroyed over some [ __ ] that's
that's
it that's talked to people because
they're stupid enough to get hooked by
it i i want to vote george lopez editor
for hustler magazine now yes
i'll bring back the [ __ ] beaver
like the whole shave thing is not
happening for me not that i've seen a
[ __ ] in a long time but ah if i saw one
same
thing i've been longer for me
[Laughter]
have you been in many relationships
i haven't by the way no i would i would
not say that that worked out for me no
me neither i love that i love inanimate
objects more than i love people
same um
i
i
i think i have a problem um
be like kind of bending to others and
i'm learning that
you know what i mean like yeah i know
what you mean
yeah
i said bending two not bending four
i do that after five
i i i've been with my partner for seven
years and this is the longest
relationship i've ever been in and it is
it's hard for me and i think maybe for
everyone but
i find it very hard to think about
another person
because it is not the way i'm
wired so like i have to talk to my
therapist and be like how do i think
about other people please help me what
does he say he says well sit down you're
not only child are you i'm the oldest
child okay yeah i'm just selfish and i i
know that's how i'm wired so i have to
like actually sit down and i have to
make sure like oh gil has feelings and
that's important
and i have to know that gil has feelings
so i don't hurt gills wow okay instead
of being like well i didn't know gill
had feelings and i don't give a [ __ ] you
know what i mean like i have to
tr i have to practice today we're
thinking about like
i'm lucky man i'll tell you right now
i've been married 51 years
and that's why you don't hang around
with grant
you know better grant's looking for some
looking for love i'm saying are you
great are you dating anybody right now
uh not at the moment no oh wow what's
the longest relationship you've been in
uh also not super long like eight months
okay
eight months yeah what's his name
is taylor what are you the bottom or the
top in a relationship in your
heterosexual i'm the middle or are you
the emotional top or emotional bottom oh
i'm definitely the emotional top oh you
are okay
so you're looking for an emotional
bottom
i guess so you know i hadn't put in
those terms but i think that is what it
is you're welcome i'll send your bills
changing straight lives every day
hey that's that's on the bottom of the
camera
changing straight lines every day uh um
and where did you uh where did you meet
your your
but but you know in in a relationship
like that are you are you thinking are
you guys thinking like the rest of your
lives together
um i haven't thought about it till just
now uh because you know is it is it i
think even marriage could be an outdated
uh it does feel outdated we are domestic
partners which yeah um
i did not realize was gonna be so
unceremonial it was a 33 fee and they
sent us a xerox copy of something they
stamped
it was it's just like hanging on our
fridge and it's is it the same as you
went and got is it the same as it would
be if you went to city hall and got
married or
or below that wait no no there's no
right
there's nothing i can do but it was a
way to um
declare our commitment to each other
without marriage per se yeah and um i
don't know we never really think about
marriage as something that's like the
next step or like this ha you know like
it's nice to be with someone who
um we're just kind of present right it's
working like kurt russell and goldie
hawn like it's working okay yeah it's
great but you know
is there the same type of thing in
another relationship where if someone's
not there you would call them and say
hey where are you i i was expecting
you're out late or or anything like that
oh that's me yeah i i think i'm i have
abandonment issues
where like if he's not home by a certain
time i start thinking about like the
worst possible scenario i start getting
paranoid i'm like and if he doesn't pick
up i'm like oh he must be at the bottom
of the thing or i used to do that with
my mom when my mom would come late
homely from work yeah i would have like
i would start to spiral were your last
with this that was a latchkey kid right
well you were your lasky kid i think
maybe you spent a lot of time alone
alone yeah yeah and the brain just goes
wild i know man that [ __ ] was tough man
like my grandparents it was only two
people and then me my grandparents and
if for some reason they weren't there by
like 5 30.
i would flip the [ __ ] out man yeah you
know you're in this house and there's
nobody there and i would turn all the
lights on because i was afraid and then
i would go wait outside
because i didn't want to be in the house
i mean i was scared yeah and then they
would pull up and the first thing they
would say is why is every [ __ ] light
of the house
not about hey you know sorry we're late
you know we didn't want to worry you
they didn't even [ __ ] about worrying
about they never even thought about me
you know it's interesting like i i think
about a lot i'm not i'm 40 this year so
like i'm thinking about my parents a lot
and mortality and all that kind of stuff
and
i'm starting to realize that like
my
my whole generation
of my culture korean americans
really
[ __ ] up
in in a way where
they were so and every any immigrant
generation of like they were so worried
about surviving that
they they [ __ ] up the whole emotional
part
you know and we
my generation we're trying to like kind
of steer the ship and be like okay
let me forgive you for that okay so you
didn't know they came here and they
established themselves but then
establishing their business they they
they they they neglected they neglected
the people on the family yeah
and
and i think because of that even koreans
when you were talking about like when
two chicanos see each other they do this
yeah like koreans men do that too and
that has a lot to do with i think us
having a bad relationship with
how we approach our emotions
and i'm trying to fix that with you know
future generations if i do have kids but
i don't know if like i'm ready to fix
that is your partner korean he's white
i'm sorry i saw your phone
do you have something written down it's
a social class show id yeah i think the
white dude's a social claim around yeah
you're giving me slam book vibes right
now
that's so funny yeah um no he you asked
how we met we met in chicago at a show
and
um he was performing no he neither of us
were performing but he's uh is he a
comedian as well yeah he's a writer and
he does uh he's he's really um working
on his music right now he's
uh his ep is being released soon like he
he's like a one of those like annoying
people who played nine instruments oh
you know like really gifted and and
probably music was in his family too
right oh they're like partridge family
that every time they get picked back
together they're playing together and
i'm the idiot just kind of like sitting
there on a cajon you know like i'm like
banging around and
not being able to do much but they're
brilliant and wonderful people from
minnesota it's amazing man when when
when yeah oh you're from minnesota are
you
do you play an instrument uh a little
guitar uh guitar okay uh but yeah i'm
from andover you'll play a little skin
flute
from uh minneapolis okay yeah i'm
familiar yeah i was like a half hour
north of there oh okay yeah so do are
you very um
like open with your family or do you
guys like to play board games
[Laughter]
neither
shout out to my my partner's family wait
a minute but wait a minute no he's just
[ __ ] wait a minute playing a board
game is a way to be with your family and
not talk about hell yeah that's
important yeah [ __ ] play monopoly for
seven years and
you could leave the families
and not talking about one [ __ ]
emotion nothing it's so funny all my
minnesota friends love board games it's
never been my thing and my me and my
family we do not get along
yeah so you know the type
absolutely you and your family don't get
along uh me and my dad in particular oh
and why why is that
okay
i didn't have a dad
i didn't have anybody my grandfather was
not my biological grandfather oh wow so
you know i'm a little bit uh that's why
i have abandonment issues because
everybody
leaves me so i leave before anybody
that's what i that's how i do it that is
also how i do it yeah
i ain't leaving you george
oh you'll lead my bucket juice huh
i'm almost partying on friday we're
talking [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
but you know that that's how those
things manifest themselves like we leave
before
and i'm trying to figure i'm trying to
like
you know what i mean like if i have kids
i want to be able to
fix that part of me that wants to leave
before
you know what i mean like i don't want
to do that again and
i don't know what do you think is the
part that you would say that you would
leave leave somebody like what's in your
in what's in us that we would say i'm
going to leave be before because the kid
is or like it's i'm going to [ __ ] it up
right before it
you know it [ __ ] up on me it's it's one
i think it's a trauma response honestly
of me going
you're not gonna you're not gonna fool
me right like i'm gonna torpedo this
before you know what i mean like you're
not gonna catch me
you remember these are the things like
these are the emotions that
when you're doing comedy you try to get
those things in there but they're hard
because they would be considered not
funny so you're trying to like
find something that can make it appear
that
and for you to talk for us to talk about
it that
you know like i had a joke where
you know my grandmother raised me and i
said my mom
was you know very loose that's why
that's why
uh
you know you're raised by your
grandparents because your mom's out
there and then you say
how loose i could have [ __ ] her
[Laughter]
so to me
that's about as that's about as deep as
i would go in and i thought about i
wrote that thing in my 20s and have
never said it on stage oh really but
it's been in me because that's that's
the whole thing
does it do you feel like it wouldn't be
it hurts it hurts it hurts because
that's because it's the truth yeah but
it's so funny
thank you
yeah i i don't know i mean i wish i had
20 more of them i would pass guilt
but you know what i'm saying but that's
where you're like like your instincts go
there
to the truth now whether you whether you
speak the truth or not is up to you yeah
but your emotions and your heart and
your intellect will take you to a place
where you'll write something and you'll
say
i don't know if i can say that i i
respect that i have a
feature that i'm
i have a story that i want to tell but
i'm scared to
and that's how i know i need to
but
it's just not right time right now it's
really not the right time because you
know whatever you say
is open for everyone else's
interpretation
when it's not
about it doesn't matter what their
interpretation is it matters what what
you're saying but now somebody in
instagram could say yeah i saw that that
that time then they they
heckle you or they or they bombard you
with messages and you know kids
that a lot of the young kids are
committing suicide like at an a [ __ ]
crazy rate because
they're not equipped to handle any
negativity yeah where we were like we
you know i don't know if you're just
stupid or you're just dumb like your
parents were dead and
they didn't offend you but if you talk
to a kid that way now who's been coddled
and and just shown everything
to be positive
that's gonna be the they're gonna
they're gonna hurt themselves when
something doesn't go their way
and yeah i mean we're in a place where
if you look at it
tick tockers
and and youtubers they
they they believe that
all of those likes are actually people
who like them
and not somebody just pushing a [ __ ]
thumb
on on their computer yeah and they and
they can't take
the fact that
maybe one video didn't get as many views
and that they're slipping or whatever
and we we we're still spoken word
yeah we're not like we do it live we're
spoken word we're not putting a video up
there
and a tick tock and you think it's your
best and then it gets maybe 1100 when
the last one got 2500 and it ruins your
[ __ ] life yeah this better get 2 500
likes all right
gil's top is 1100 but you don't you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah they're not
equipped emotionally to handle
rejection when it's not even rejection
it can't be rejection if it comes to a
[ __ ] phone
i can't imagine being a kid now i
wouldn't say it must be i know i don't
think i would have the fortitude yeah
um yeah they're strong though they're
stronger than we were so so in your
career where would you see yourself
where you would say okay i think i'm
on a nice trajectory but what eventually
would i want to do that would make me
happy
i want to write in writer i want to be a
writer director yeah i have
i always say i have 12 stories i want to
tell yeah and that's it and i'll move on
and i i think i
i i want to leave a
signature
behind yeah you know i have i'm very
visual i know what i like i know what i
want
especially as a creator so i'd like to i
like to leave something behind and
people when people see it they're like
oh that's a peter kim joint right you
know right yeah
and uh um do you how do you write do you
journal or do you
are you right at night do you write in
your phone or how how do you process
your your your thoughts and
definitely my notes app is everything
it's you know
it's everything but i
i have to structure
or else i can't do it i have to like
tell myself
these three hours get into it it doesn't
matter if it's garbage like just [ __ ] it
out
and you know who wrote like that
seinfeld what you said right like yeah
we'll try to he he'd say start to write
five minutes a day which is really hard
at the beginning yeah and then try to
build up to an hour a day
and i try to tell mayan that and you
know mine my daughter
doesn't do it and i told her 11 years
ago so if she had done it 11 years ago i
mean
i don't know what she does
in her time i don't ask her but
i sold the show to nbc but also
she has a she has a responsibility to be
better on her own without me checking on
her
and you can only
you can only hope that she's doing that
like i can't say you know we have an
obligation to be prepared
she has an obligation to be prepared but
she's never had an opportunity this big
so i would hope that
in that she would she would uh you know
be preparing
yeah i bet she is yeah yeah and i've
i've just learned that everybody has a
their own process and
something that works for me will not
work for someone else another writer
right across so like
you know i think that's the coolest
thing about being a writer is that you
you approach it so differently and then
you that's what makes it special is that
it's your unique but also when people
have either tick tocks or instagrams and
things like that where you can
on your phone create
uh you can do bits you can create little
movies on your on your phones that you
know we weren't able to do when i was
growing up it had to be you had to go to
a club to
perform to try to be good but you know
in the computer or all that stuff you
can edit things and you see i see them
every day yeah people trying to be
trying to there's some funny [ __ ] on
tick tock i haven't i laugh out loud on
tick tock all the time i think they're
geniuses
i don't have the the what if you've
gotten that right if you got them in
front of people they wouldn't be yeah i
think it's a different skill it's a
different skill live performance is
i mean it's the great equalizer do you
do you think that people who are on tick
tock that are able to go viral
can go to a larger platform or are they
only good in 15 second or a minute
intervals which which is
misleading to be funny for a minute
i can't see these people going live on
stage i think most of them are probably
just that form
some of them might just be like bull
burnham who like came from youtube right
so like he wasn't doing it for me but
he's brilliant yeah you know so like
there's one in a million out of that but
most of them were probably forced are
you a fan of comedians from the past or
yeah how far back do you go
uh you mean american comedy or korean
community in uh korean comedy i go back
to like oh wow you know 80s and 70s
because i i grew up watching those
people who oh and who are those guys i
mean you wouldn't know any of their
names yeah almost like game flowers and
all those yeah it's like a variety show
type it's all very physical comedy yeah
clowning you know that kind of stuff
that's my heart like that's true that's
the heart of my comedy you watch them in
korean do that right yeah yeah and a lot
of it is like
um status based and you know oh i'm the
i'm the you know very three stooges type
type of you know comedy
and um but here in america you know i
grew up watching seinfeld larry david
um
i you know i studied richard pryor
um and those guys like i'm a big fan of
american stand-up comedy it's it's an
art form that's i studied richard bryer
yeah
yeah also
queer i hear
uh bye had some queer experiences yeah
yeah
with some very hot people
yeah i'm like that's that's hot i wish i
was there in the 70s like in the cocaine
driven 70s like there was some wild [ __ ]
going on man yeah there was some [ __ ]
there was some drinking daily on the
daily but uh um
yeah richard pryor is my how's mine that
was your guy my dude yeah my my guy that
i watched live was attel
and um i watched dave chappelle in the
cellar yeah
yeah yeah the seller was a great player
all those guys louis c kayles guys went
in there godfrey was
back
yeah god rest his soul man you know that
dude man
like those guys
you know
to think that
bob saget louie
and gilbert all went in the same year
it's just
it's it's almost honest it's almost
unbelievable to me oh you mean gilbert
godfrey yeah oh i was laughing because
no sorry his name is god free oh god for
all of africa
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah all right yeah
yeah yeah that's a good guy he's still
alive yeah yeah that's what you really
when he said that i was like wait are
you being watched
actually that's what i heard too so i'm
glad we clarified
well i would say god for gilbert god
free than god free yeah that's such a
funny like almost drag queenie gay thing
to like roast about someone if you don't
like them you know someone you don't
like let's say like donald trump oh god
rest is soul
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
yeah and where can people see you where
can we uh
season two of em uh of fairfax is coming
out on amazon june 10th so you can check
um the gang game
it's about the fairfax district in la
and it's about four middle school kids
wait a minute like we're cbs yeah yeah
yeah that whole strip and it's all about
like hypebeat hypebeast culture sneaker
culture like what's hot what's not and
it's about like four middle school kids
who are like trying to keep up with it
are you familiar with them no not at all
so so one morning i'm going to the
airport and we're going down fairfax and
there's 1200 [ __ ] people in line in
front of this little store
and i'm like it's 5 30 in the morning
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on and
they were dropping some shoe yeah and
they were at that hour you know there
was [ __ ]
lines
a shoe
like a new shoe was coming out
you know i told him that that that my
fetish was was foot cleavage like when a
woman's wearing a pump
toe cleavage
could you
could you toe [ __ ] somebody no you could
talk [ __ ] someone you're small enough no
between the two between the two feet
yeah uh
my wife will die but i gotta tell you
this the other day at the house
look at what i said hey what are hammer
toes
and she's serious says yeah what are
hammer toes
and she says
well you know when women wear those
things and you got this thing
and my son looks there he says no mom
those are camel toes they're talking
about hammer toes
is as attractive as female camel toe
no
no male count is disgusting all right we
can stop doing the podcast that's all i
wanted to know
that's awesome thanks for coming in dude
thank you for having me absolutely a
pleasure to meet you this was really fun
thank you yeah yeah thanks for coming
and thank you for being open of course
yeah you don't like shout out your
socials or anything like that
uh just where people yeah at peter kz is
my socials um
yeah
i i don't know i don't do social media
that much well there you know i'm good
for you no but i i just don't i think
i'm too old i don't know how to like
keep up with it but you know if you if
you i do live shows in la if you if
you're going to like come out oh are we
still going or not yeah we're starting
oh um i need to shout this out i'm going
to be in chicago
um june 12th but also that weekend june
17th through the 19th i'm going to be
headlining dc comedy loft so please come
out to that uh where's dc comedy live on
k street
i don't know
i'm sorry
i think it's a
it's a new place or
i don't know
i don't know if it's new um you know i
worked at a place in dc
that uh was a three-story place the top
story was like a nightclub the second
story was like the comedy club and down
below they had a strip club
and
you know almost like back in the day
where you would do the first show
and then i'd go down to the strip club
and hang out
until this guy came in the doorway and
said you know give me like 10 minutes
and i'd go up and do the show and then i
would go back down to the strip club i
mean amazing i don't think this place is
like no i think there's a beer garden
downstairs
i think that's it's the dc community and
beer baron tavis yes exactly yeah yeah i
don't think i don't think that's that
way i think that's
this yeah yeah but those places were
[ __ ] great man guys that's the [ __ ]
that you would hear about you know i'll
do a show
then go down and just check out chicks
have a couple sit with me and then go
back up i'll be right back after that
hang on that sounds funny awesome man
i went to a comedy place over there in
washington dc and louis anderson was
performing i went with a friend
uh she was a former cop here and then uh
she had restaurants over there we went
together and
sat there and
my laughter and afterwards was he funny
yeah he was
this is years ago and he comes up and
he's
after the show he says god you were
great he says man
he says you localized no i'm from l.a
i'm going back home tomorrow you know
i'll be back in italy i'm going to be in
la next week hey come on out to the show
and he wanted me to go
see him over there i never did
but louie i did a thing with louie at
noho for sherry shepard that that
created her own language gym and then
louie goes josh why are you thinking
this like
my shirts are so big that it's starting
to look like the logo of the super bowl
xxx bb
one two i mean he was the best man
he was the best that's great
awesome
you are still here god rest his soul
thanks so much for coming up thank you
guys thank you thank you
you